one of the biggest problems for us were
the border controls with traffic jams of up to 30
kilometers with the normal day should
have been a public holiday in between
, we at least called the side
up to a radius of up to 80 kilometers, which is
extended after the public holidays and that's
how it is somehow  ne impertinence for
the drivers who have spent the whole day in the truck
that is an application to others receives
the refrigerator was empty and wanted to
go shoot the
wester completely finished at driving time only that it is just
without supply so for the next
10 is us  unfortunately not
i personally would wish if
the borders were opened again
now that border controls would be
completely eliminated back to the level
of corona times
[music]